is there a difference between a woman
that's married or in a long-term
relationships
no no listen because
you're married
see my brother to my brothers they're
Muslim so they do the marriage thing
quick right so they'll meet someone
maybe they'll get married after a couple
of weeks to my brothers a couple of
weeks yeah like it's a quick that's how
it is
it's like it's a quicker process than in
like Western Society like in Western
Society it will take you a lot longer to
get married so in essence I'm I'm asking
what's the difference between some let's
say she got married says
uh free well I got married pretty quick
as well so this is what I mean were you
Muslim or something I'm Muslim yeah this
is what I mean how long were you married
for uh so I got married after three
months
so let's say I've been in a relationship
with a guy for five years we've not been
married yeah okay for whatever reason
now let's say she's been she got married
after three months do you see a
difference
wait wait okay so I'll tell you how men
see it it's like what to them to that to
them to them it's like why weren't you
worth marrying so so to me to to them
it's like oh she got married after three
months I I trust men like trust each
other to vet women so to them it's like
then there's something wrong with you
because you were with like one they
would ask why would you be with a guy
for five years without marriage and then
two like why didn't he think you were
worth marrying me personally and I'm not
trying I'm not trying to be like rude
but I'm saying like that's just how men
view it me personally I don't put much
value on marriage because can I just
give it and wait wait and so I I
understand like where where you're
coming from because like honestly the
marriage contract is so bad nowadays
like it's it's it's horrible and I I
mean I understand like why men don't
want to get married and I especially in
the west and in the UK yes I'm 100 with
you but like to her so like let's say
you both had a child the men would look
at her and say she was so Val she was so
valuable to that guy that he was that
she was worth it like like to like he
was willing to take that risk for her
and so she gets like a higher status and
I'm not and I'm not saying that's that's
right or fair I'm just saying like oh
this is this is how this is this is how
men view it gospel
he was a virgin and he wouldn't have sex
guys will just give you a kid now just
not raise it because no they don't have
to bear it they don't have at the end of
the day see when I have a kid is in me I
have to push out and I'm left with it
women but women wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
please respect the [ __ ] home you're
gonna get muted stop okay so this is the
thing like
women pick those men and and I just
don't buy that women are Bamboozled and
they have no idea that these no I don't
believe that right and so I don't
believe that so we we are we are in
control of sex we have 41s 41 forms of
birth control yeah abortions are are
free here and legal so we are completely
in control of who is born I can't like
that woman deserves what she gets yeah
yeah yeah because I'm 30 and I have no
kids for a reason right right that's
what I'm saying I believe the goal that
gets pregnant by guys
is an abortion so no but what I'm trying
to say is if you don't believe in
abortion don't let man you and then
let's have sex without Consciousness but
you could have contraception and still
get pregnant I think what Paul's saying
is we should be responsible it's very
it's very and I'm not I know you have a
kid so I'm not trying to come at you you
get an IUD that's 99.5 effective you
only really get pregnant three to five
days of the month when you're ovulate I
know there's exceptions but every girl
every girl that I know personally that
had an abortion or had an unwanted
pregnancy personally I just go off of
what I see in real life and the numbers
they were irresponsible in some way like
some of the girls weren't on birth
control and you were letting him finish
in you what was wrong if you know you're
not on birth control if you know you're
not life control and you get pregnant
and you don't believe in abortions
personally
that's your business let me ask you a
question though as a as the woman who
has who was seeing another men's yeah
right oh I see another man yeah who's
got a woman yeah if you got pregnant
would you keep his baby no no no you
wouldn't I as much as
um I would say that you love him and you
always when I say love is this I used to
love the word love very Loosely however
no I would never put myself in that
position
I just know he's willing to cheat and I
like him and his and your help
is he simple for you because that's what
it kind of says
no but you said when he calls you when
you call him you don't pick up but when
he calls you you pick up right he calls
you no do you know why yeah
let me explain because basically he has
a goal right so I don't have a man so I
have no attachments no I have to hide
the secret form you do have a plan it's
him true all right so I'll say and
potentially
why she don't no no thank you I'm not
delusional that's the one on her head
listen Okay okay if I call him
potentially he might be with his God all
right so do you have a protection let me
ask you a question so do you have other
men then yes
oh
so you do yeah how how long like because
you're 30. I'm like no I'm saying I'm
just genuinely wait wait wait so so
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35. so so
yeah and and in that time you have to
get to know someone convince them to do
you know because wait wait wait how how
long do you want to play these games no
no realistically I have guys that I
could just give me a baby would look
after baby they're good friends than me
and yeah but you wouldn't give me yeah
right right right right real literally
if I really thought listen I my time's
up I need to have a kid there's guys I
could do that with if that's what I want
right but I'm just no I'm just 100 no
I'm just genuinely no no it's not it's
not it's not a thing
wait wait wait wait wait
so so I'm just genuinely asking like how
long do you want to play these games
no no no no
no no no sorry sorry
it was the edge sorry sorry I just I'm
saying don't give me a long sentence
just how long do you want to play these
games for don't just answer until I meet
someone I want to have a kid with okay
can I ask you a question now can I ask
you a question at this moment at this
very moment would you get rid of a baby
I mean a committed relationship that I
care for that they've shown that they
have good traits to be a father to be a
good husband or if I got to an age that
was just too old that I thought I'm 40
and I'm single I have very good good
male friends
so it's just like if I was in your shoes
like [ __ ] if if I'm gonna be a side
chick anyway I would just compete figure
out what the hell he wants to try to be
it like if I was if if that's what
you're gonna do anyway or like or just
get it off
and it's funny do you know what I'd say
you know I'd say you know I'm I'm gonna
go a little bit deeper right yeah
and go to self-esteem yeah
if you are a woman who is happy yeah
self-esteem wise yeah with being with a
Madness not your man right yeah knowing
that he's never going to commit to you
yeah there's a self-esteem issue there
okay so I'm not even gonna answer this
is my cousin so let him answer for me no
no no no no because I'm biased right you
see me there's a self-esteem issue there
though see the difference for me is
right if I if I happen to like someone
right the majority because how how much
do you value yourself how much do you
value yourself as a woman as an
individual hang on wait how much do you
value yourself as a woman as an
individual that you will allow yourself
yeah to be constantly chasing after and
just just please just let me speak right
to allow yourself to be chasing after
another man's I saw another girl's man
right and be happy with that I don't
know what's going on with you inside
your life with this within the 30 years
I don't know right but on a self-esteem
issue right you're actually happy with
this arrangement
you're happy with it I don't chase him
no it doesn't matter
but what I'm trying to say is that
you're happy with that Arrangement
that's so selfish
like someone who who doesn't have no no
self-stage are you not gonna live
whatsoever
that she's happy to be a side chick yeah
and happy to sleep with with with other
men's around and still in her head think
at some point in her life she will
settle down she'll find her husband she
would build a family yeah because that's
what women generally want impossible
okay I'm just I'm just gonna be real
though most women can and most women do
like yeah yeah it's not what the guys
they want but like it's a Sim epidemic
look at the look at the title of the how
many yeah how many step daddy's we got
out here it's not fun but let's just be
real
I'm not saying it should be that way but
I'm just saying there you know
saying like I feel like they want to say
side chicks have low self-esteem
whatever and this is going to be an
unpopular opinion I just I just feel
like there are a group of women that
will be side chicks but they compete and
they try to steal your man I'm just
saying if you're gonna do it I I
wouldn't sign up I wouldn't sign up to
do it I'm just saying if you're gonna do
it anyway you might not go to the whole
race
do you know why I don't want to steal
your mind someone that's been excited
because I I you cheat so I can't trust
you I don't want to take you from
yourself
before me before me before because we're
gonna close out soon budget yeah it's
good sex but you know as you because
you're 30 right yeah as you get to 35
and you get to 40 and you've got no kids
wait wait you got no kids and you've got
no future you looking ahead of you right
that loneliness is gonna set it
let me finish the loneliness is gonna
set him right and you're gonna look at
all of your girlfriends around you who
have got kids yeah and have got whether
you're sisters maybe your girlfriends
blah blah and you're gonna feel
empty yeah you're gonna feel empty
everything and the thing is it's like
I don't like I don't get it I'm not
gonna I don't I don't understand how
that is your life
can I just say what I think you're
saying and you can tell me yeah that's
fine in your head You're Gonna Keep
sleeping with him because of the good
the good sex that's why and so in your
head you don't want to be with you try
something yeah
so you're gonna keep sleeping with him
because of the good sex yeah and until
you meet someone new yeah and when you
meet it but you wouldn't if he broke up
with his girlfriend tomorrow you
wouldn't be with him even though you
love even though you love him Loosely
a year and a half is a long time okay if
I'm just putting myself in your shoes if
I was sleeping with a guy for a year and
a half and he was giving like if I was
in your shoes I would probably be close
to in love with him if not okay I'm just
I'm just so I should apologize for using
that way so because I use it very
Loosely
okay
okay so I should also explain the reason
why I see this guy as much as I do
because we're in the same Social Circle
now okay okay but I'm on post side
I'm just saying like if if you if you
look if I was you I would either compete
for him or get out because you're not
gonna be opened like we all know we all
know when we're getting like like if you
you're not open to meeting someone I am
100 really I feel like I'm a very niche
market of person so when I speak my
opinion
my constant convulsion is I do not cap
no at the end of the day like I said he
gives good sex and I enjoy sometimes
am I not open to meeting other people
you have sex with other guys right yeah
yeah so I'm saying so
you when you say you're open so you're
literally open
not in that you're literally open yeah
some people post as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible